العفو الدوليه تصف تشكيله لجنه لتقص
الحقائق بنقطه تحول و واشنطن ترى فيها
التزام دوليا بمحاسبه طهران
العراق يشرعوا بتعزيز قواته او يشرع
بتعزيز قواته على الحدود مع تركيا وايران
بعد خروقات امنيه من البلدين الجارين
منافسات المونديال تدخل يومها السادس
ومنتخب البرازيل بصدد تقييم حاله اصابته
نيمار
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
قالت منظمه العفو الدوليه
الشعب الايراني
قرار المجلس تشكيل لجنه لتقص الحقائق حول
القمع في ايران بانه قرار تاريخي واعتبرته
ايضا نقطه تتحولا طال انتظارها للتعامل مع
الحصانه المنهجيه للمسؤولين الايرانيين
القومي
الموافقه على قرار مجلس حقوق الانسان
التابع للامم المتحده بشان احتجاجات ايران
بانها مؤشر على التزام المجتمع الدولي
بمحاسبه النظام الايرانيه على القمع
الهمجي مشددا على استمرار جهود الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها لمحاسبته
طعم طهران
من مشاهد الاطفال الذين يقتلون وصور
النساء التي يتم ضربهن في الشوارع
والاشخاص المحكومين بالاعدام راينا موجات
من الاحتجاجات في ايران خلال السنوات
الماضيه او التي تنادي بالعداله والمساواه
والكرامه واحترام حقوق الانسان وقبلت
بالعمق والقمع واستعمال القوه المبالغ
فيها وغير الضروريه يجب ان تتوقف العقليه
القديمه لاصحاب السلطه في مجابهه
الاحتجاجات لانها لا تنفع على العكس تفاقم
من الاوضاع نحن الان نواجه ازمه على اعلى
المستويات على الصعيد حقوق الانسان في
ايران
امريكي ايضا حيث قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
واصل دعم الشعب الايراني في مواجهته قمع
السلطان الايراني
المحتاجين والعنف ضد النساء والفتيات
مشيرا الى عملي بلاده على اقصاء ايران من
لجنه الامم المتحده المعنيه بحقوق المراه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تلبيه لي دعوه اللي اضراب العام في ايران
امس اغلق عدد من التجار والرجال الاعمال
ابواب محالهم ومتاجيرهم واضرب العديد من
العمال والموظفين عن العمل باغلب المدن
والمحافظات وفي السياق اعلنت نقبه العمال
الحره ان عمال شركه
في قزوين اضربوا عن العمل ونظم وتجمع عن
احتجاجيا اما في كردستان
عمال البناء والحرفيين بيننا دائما لمطالب
المواطنين طلبت فيه بمحاكمه المتورطين في
قتل العمال المتظاهرين ووقف قتل المواطنين
في الشوارع بشكل فوري هذا هو كان مركزه
تعاون لحزب الكردستاني مجموعه شباب احياء
زهران ومجموعات اخرى طلبت خلال الايام
الماضيه الشعب الايراني بالاضراب عن العمل
ونزول الى الشوارع امس الخميس لدعم
المتظاهريننا والمطالبه بمحاكم المتور
حطينا بقتل العمال المتظاهرين
وقد تنوعت طرق الاحتجاجات في ايران
والتعبير عن السخط في البلاد من تظاهرات
الى اعتصامات مرورا بالاضطرابات وكتابه
الشعارات على جدران مؤسسات النظام وصولا
الى احتجاج الطلبه في المدارس والجامعه
ومؤخرا مطالبه جماعيه للاستقال من
البرلمان الايراني للتضامن مع المحتاجين
ومناضتي قمعهم وقتلهم من قبل الاجهزه
الامنيه الايرانيه ودعت مجموعه من الكتاب
في محافظه كردستان غربي البلاد في بيان
الى استقاله جماعيه للبرلمانيين تضامنا مع
الشعب الحزين وفق وصف البيان
ومع تنوعي اشكال الاحتجاجات في ايران
تتنوعوا ايضا اساليب نظام القمعيه وفق
تقارير غربيه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه وطبقا لنتائج تحقيقاتها لمقاطع
فيديو متعلقه بالاحتجاجات كشفت وجه جديد
لقوه النظام التي تقوم باستخدام سيارات
الاسعاف للتسلل الى تجمعات واعتقالي
للمتظاهرين وبدوره اكد المتحدث باسمي
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان يتسلل لا قوه
الامن في سيارات الاسعاف الاعتقال
المتظاهرين يظهرون مدى خوف المرشد
الايراني من شعبان
وبعد تاييده للاحتجاجات الشعبيه في ايران
وانتقاده الدعم بلاده للمليشيات التابعه
لها في المنطقه القت السلطات الايرانيه
القبض على اللاعب الايراني الشهير ورياض
غفوري
لانضاف او لينضم بذلك الى قائمه رياضيين
الذين سجلتهم ايران الى جانب باقي
المعتقلين من المعارضين
[موسيقى]
اكد السكرتيره مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع
في اوكرانيا اوليكس سيداني لوف مقتل
مستشارين عسكريين ايرانيين تواجدوا في
القرم لمساعده روسيا في قياده طائره مسيره
بحسب بريطانيا المسؤول الاوكراني هدد
باستدافي اي عسكريا ايرانيا موجوده على
الارض الاوكرانيه التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
الحدود البيلاروسيا الاوكرانيه مرحله من
التوتر تسحبها عمليات مراقبه كبيره من قبل
طرفين هذا وتستركيا في عمليات بناء جدار
فاصل على طول الشريط الحدوديه
توتر كبير وحاله من الغليان على الشريط
الحدودي الفاصل بين اوكرانيا وابيلاروسيا
الخط الفاصل بين الدولتين لم يعد اسلاكا
شائكه بل قنبله موقوته
على شفل انفجار تعزيزات لحرس الحدود
البلاروسي يقابلها دعم عسكري اوكراني في
بعض الاحيان بالمعدات الثقيله كليه
مختلفه تحدث خلال الفتره الاخيره على سبيل
المثال دخلت مره في فصل الصيف وعنصر
اوكراني نحو الاراضي البله روسيه وكان
يمسك قنبله يدويه ويهدد بالتفجيرها واسعف
حينها زملائه الامر وصحبه
في ظل ظروف الحاليه تقوم مينسكربيبه موسكو
بيراصد التغييرات المتقلبه حاله استنفارا
للتدخل السريع لدى اي طارئ محتمل خاصه ان
الاخيره تقوم بمراقبه الحدود بشكل كامل
بين البلدين عبد الجواد الروش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث من الحدود البيلاروسيه
الاوكرانيه
بلاده لم تواجهه اي ضربه
مشيرا الى ان الدمار الذي اعلنته اوكرانيا
هو ناتج عن صواريخ الدفاع الجوي
الاوكرانيا المنتشره في المنطقه السكنيه
بحسبه تعبيره
ضربه واحده
فكل الدمار الذي اعلنه النظام الاوكراني
داخل المدينه نتج عن سقوط صواريخ اطلقتها
انظمه دفاع جوي اجنبي واوكرانيه منتشره في
مناطق سكنيه بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه
شرعت القوه العراقيه بتعزيز وحدتها على
الحدود مع كل من تركيا وايران في اقليم
كردستان شمالي البلاد بعد خروقات امنيه من
البلدين الجارين طالت اهدافا داخل الحدود
العراقيه وكان اجتماع للمجلس الوزاري
للامن الوطني العراقي عقده رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني الخميس بحضور
رئيس اركان قوه البشمركه الكرديه اسرع عن
وضع خطه لاعادتنا قوات الحدود العراقيه
على طول الحدود مع ايران وتركيا بهدف
تامين متطلبات لدعم اللوجستيه لقيادته
الحدود بما يمكنها من انجازمها
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
انتخاب السعوديه رئيسا للمجلس التنفيذي
لمنظمه السياحه العالميه تابعه للامم
المتحده
اهلا بكم من جديد
على نتيجه استفتاء الاجره عبر المنصه
واستمر 24 ساعه قرر اصدار عفو عام عن
الحسابات المجمده على موقعه واعاده
تفعيلها اعتبارا من الاسبوع المقبل
من المشتركين في المنصه التصويت عبر
تغريداتهم في استفتاء حول منحي الحسابات
المجمده عفوا عاما شرط الا تكون انتهت
القوانين او ارسلت بريدا عشوائيا فاضا
وكانت النتيجه
72% من المغردين على سؤالي ماسك بنعم
تراجع مؤشر خطاب الكراهيه الى الثلث على
تويتر خلال الشهرين الماضي
الملياردير
على جهوده الكبيره بعد انخفضت تغريدات
والكراهيه من عشره ملايين الى المليونين
ونصف المليون ما بين شهرين اكتوبر ونوفمبر
وفي وقت سابق كشف تقرير لمركز مكافحه
الكراهيه الرقميه عن استخدام العنصريه على
تويتر ارتفع ثلاثه اضعاف مقارنه بالاعوام
السابقه منذ استحواذ ايلون ماسك الرقم
[موسيقى]
تويتر توصيل
فرع الشركه الفرنسيه
من هنا خرج مدير الفرع الفرنسي لشركه
تويتر
معلنا استقالته من منصبه هذه الاستقاله
كانت اشاره واضحه على ان المشكلات التي
تواجه تويتر تعدت حدود سان فرانسيسكو
ووصلت الى باريس
استقالته من تويتر على تويتر لكن ماذا
تعني هذه الاستقاله بالنسبه لمؤثرين
فرنسيين على تويتر ثم هؤلاء تحدث الان عن
حاله من الضياع وعدم اليقين حول تاثير ما
يواجهه تويتر على المستخدمين
كلهم
من التغيرات التي تحدث من غير الواضح الى
انها ستذهب الامور هل سيكون هناك توازن
اكثر ام اقل ما نراه حتى الان انا الاموره
هذه المشكلات تتعلق بالدرجه الاولى بمساء
الى قانونيه اذن التباينات بين القوانين
الفرنسيه والامريكيه كبيره جدا في مصر
في لحظه ماء سوف يصطدم ذلك بالقوانين
الفرنسيه وسندخل في الواقع تويتر هو عالم
الافتراضي لكن لديه تاثيرات قويه على
الواقع ويقدر عدد المستخدمين الفرنسيين
النشطين على تويتر شهريا ب 16 مليون
مستخدم حتى الان لم تؤثر المشكلات التي
تعصف بالعصفور الازرق على استخدامهم
للموقع فادي دهوك العربيه باريس
[موسيقى]
قلعه طبيب منتخب البرازيل انه يجب عليهم
الانتظار من 24 الى 48 ساعه لتقييم عصابه
نيمار في الكاحل باقي اخبار المنافسات
المنافسات كاس العالم طبعا في هذا الموسم
[موسيقى]
تحيا الرياضيه اهلا بكم الى المجاز
الرياضي تتراقب جماهير السعوديه بفرغ
الصبر مواجهه منتخب بلاده امام بولندا
السبت المقبل ضمن المعترك العالمي المنتخب
السعودي سيكون امام فرصه كتابه فصل جديد
في تاريخ المشاركاته الموندياليه وحسم
التاهل الى الدور الثاني في حال الفوز وهو
ما يبدو ممكنا بعد الفوز المبهر على
الارجنتين في الافتتاح سيعور المنتخب
السعودي على استمرار تالقي قائده الجديد
في مونديال سالم الدوسري بعد اصابه سلمان
الفرج اثناء المباراه الافتتاحيه
الاسباني مليون لوف سعودي ديل بول بريفويو
في السعوديه
يعملوا منتخب قطر في الابقاء على امله
بالمنافسه على بطاقه التاهل عندما يواجه
السنغال على ستاد ثم ما العنابي بعد
خسارته لمباراه الافتتاحيه امام اكوادور
يسعى لتجنب الخروج المبكر من دور
المجموعات اعلن الاتحاد السنغالي لكره
القدم ان لاعب خط الوسط شيخ كويتي يعاني
من اصابه وسيكون غير متاح على الارجح
لمواجهه قطر التي تعول على دعم جماهيرها
وقد يستغل القطريون على غرار الهولنديين
غياب الهداف السنغاليه بسبب الاصابات وفرض
ايقاع على المباراه منذ بدايتها
ااا اعتقد
المباراه الماضيه صفحه ونطوط الفريق قوى
الصفحه من بعد المباراه مباشره
بدين استعداداتنا للمباراه القادمه اييه
اعتقد ااا
الفريق الحين يعني قاعد يمشي في الطريق
الصحيح ان شاء الله
ومباراه القادمه ان شاء الله الفريق بيكون
بيكون متجهزيته ان شاء الله بيعطيك كل ما
عنده باذن الله في المباراه القادمه
على ارضه الاخطاء ممنوعه ونريد ان نحقق
حلم الجماهير السنغاليه جميعنا فريق واحد
ونعرف ان مندي سيكون في افضل جاهزيه ويؤدي
بافضل صوره ممكنه
قدري تشارلز منتخب البرازيلي فوزها بهدفين
من دون مقابل على منتخب صربيا بعد الشوط
الاول عانا فيه البرازيليون كثيرا من
طلبات الدفاع الخصم تمكن ريتشاردن من
تسجيل الهدف الاول في الدقيقه الثانيه و60
قبل ان يضيف الهدف الثاني في تسديد
اكروباتيه مع اعتبر الهدف الاجمل في
البطوله حتى الان لتصدر البرازيل مجموعتها
السابعه بثلاث نقاط بينما يتدين الصلب من
دون
[تصفيق]
حققت سويسرا التي تخوض العرس العالمي
للمره الثانيه عشره والخامس على التوالي
حقت فوزها الثالث عشر في نهائيات بعد
تغلبها على الكاميرون بهدف من دون مقابل
في افتتاح مباريات المجموعه السابعه هدف
لقاء الوحيد سجله
الكاميرونيه عند الدقيقه الثامنه
والاربعين لتحصيل السويسرا اول ثلاث نقاط
لها في المنافسه
[تصفيق]
منتخب البرتغال من الدخول بقوه في منافسات
كاس العالم بالفوز على غانا بثلاثه اهداف
مقابل هدفين في جوله الاولى من المجموعه
السابعه ووجدت البرتغال صعوبه في هذه
الشباك في البلاك ستورز وانتظر الشوط
الثاني لتسجيل الهدف الاول في لقاء للركله
الجزاء نجح ب تنفيذها رونالدو هانتمكنت من
العوده بهدف لقائد المنتخب
[تصفيق]
واصبح كريستيانو رونالدو اول لاعب يسجل في
خمسه نسخ من كاس العالم في التاريخ هو
الهدف الثامن لصاروخ ماديرا في بطوله
العالميه يحتاج رونالدو هدفا واحدا ليعدل
رقم ايزيو الهداف التاريخي للبرتغال في
البطوله القريه
استهلا منتخب اوروغواي مباراته في مونديال
2022 بتعادل سلبي امام كوريا الجنوبيه
الخميس على استاد المدينه التعليميه في
العاصمه الدوحه بالمجموعه الثامنه فشل
المنتخبان في استغلال كافه الفرص التي
اطيحت لهما امام المرمى يحصل كل منهما على
نقطه يلتقى منتخب
البرتغاليه يوم الاثنين المقبل في جوله
الثانيه فيما يلعب منتخب كوريا الجنوبيه
مع منتخب غانا في اليوم
تنفست جماهير الانجليزيه السعداء بعد عوده
هاري كين الى التدريبات الكامله اليوم
استعدادا لمواجهه الولايات المتحده في
المجموعه الثانيه ضرب قائد الاسود الثلاثه
بشكل فردي امس قبل انضمامه الى تدريبات
جماعيه وايظل صانع العاب ليستر سيتي
والمنتخب جيمس ماديسن غائبا عن التدريبات
واخر مواجهه منذليه بينهما كانت في جنوب
افريقيا حينها تمكنت الولايات المتحده من
الفرد التعادل على منتخب الاسود الثلاثه
والتاهل كاول المجموعه الى الدور الثاني
يا هاوس كورس
لذلك من الصعب ان يكون خارج التشكيله
[موسيقى]
وزاره السياحه السعوديه عن انتخاب المملكه
رئيسا للمجلس التنفيذي لمنظمه السياحه
العالميه التابعه للامم المتحده وذلك خلال
اجتماع الدوره
117 التي عقدت بمراكش في المغرب لتصبح
السعوديه اول دوله خليجيه تشتغل هذا
المنصب واكد وزير السياحه السعوديه
المملكه ستواصل دعمها لشهودي اعاده تصميم
القطاع السياحي بما يساعد على تعزيز النمو
المستدامه تحديات مستقبليه
وجودنا في رئاسه هذا المجلس التنفيذي
سيجعل من المنظمه اقوى ويجعل من اعضاء
المجلس اكثر ااا يعملون بشكل اكثر تناغما
واستقرارا اليوم في صراعات كبيره في ال ال
ال المجلس التنفيذي البنوك تاخذ مننا وقت
طويل واعتقد انه جزء كبير من اللي يحصل
الان هو ضعف في التنسيق قبل اجتماعات
المجلس وعدنا الدول الاعضاء انه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بصفتها الرئيس الدوره
القادمه راح اعمل على تحسين اداء المجلس
التنفيذي بما يعزز من دور المنظمه ويخدم
مصالح الدول الاعضاء
حسام هذه النشره الى العناوين
العفو الدوليه توصيف تشكيله لجنه لتقص
الحقائق بنقطه تحول
وواشنطن ترى فيها التزام دوليا بمحاسبتك
العراق يشرع بتعزيز قواته على الحدود مع
تركيا وايران بعد خروقات امنيه بين او من
البلدين الجرين
ونفسه كاس العالم تدخل يومها السادس
والبرازيل تتوقع استمرار نيمار رغم اصابته
بالكاحل
حسام متابعه مشاهدتينا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]